neon jellyfish Evangelion is one of the
most iconic anime in the history of the
medium since originally airing on TVs
had an enormous amount of releases on
laserdisc VHS DVD blu-ray Game Boy
Advance some select Japanese washing
machines I'm pretty sure there's an
embedded copy on the Voyager spacecraft
for aliens to discover and yet somehow
copies were so hard to find it across
the total of your entire life savings
when you first unborn child to purchase
but after all these years Netflix have
answered our prayers are made it
available to the mass public worldwide
and for the first time a new generation
of people or finally get to experience
the desolation of the virgin Sun or snap
versus the Chad third impact and I'm
glad to say they finally pulled through
this time and given us the adaptation we
were waiting for
for decades countless critics and fans
have meticulously analyzed every frame
every piece of dialogue peeling back the
layers to uncover what visionary
director Hayao Miyazaki was trying to
say and it's here over 20 years later
that we still have no [ __ ] clue as the
titular kaiju mecha slice of life drama
idol dance-off horse-racing gangster
open-world third-person shooter action
game it's a title that's left its mark
on history if you wanted the few people
who still have no idea what Evangelion
is all about even up all these years
here's a really quick plot synopsis it's
run away I'm not surprised that was it
now Netflix have made a reputation for
tinkering with classic franchises to
make the fact and there is no exception
here during this release the decision
was made to completely redub the entire
thing in an utterly confusing move as
everyone knows the original dub was a
flawless rendition already perfect for
mainstream consumption and to add to the
confusion even further they'll replace
the original cars and hide some no-name
voice actors to do this Doug they didn't
even get Keanu Reeves to voice Shinji
which would have been the perfect
casting come on Netflix get it together
you can spend a hundred million dollars
licensing friends but you can't even get
my boy Keanu man if you're gonna
disappoint me like this at least get
Danny DeVito for kendo along with this
legacy it also has the most popular
anime opening of all time in cool angel
thesis that has been covered by bands
and artists all over the world including
the glory gospel LMFAO and my personal
favorite a calculator why wouldn't it
flakes have offered a skip intro button
this comes later this is actually a
covert sting operation as skipping cruel
angels thesis was declared as a war
crime by the UN in 1999 so far a total
of seven people have been detained where
as per legislation they are publicly
shamed forced to watch 200 hours of the
lucky star opening and sentenced to be
destroyed of course it wouldn't be
Evangelion without controversy and this
time there has been plenty around the
retranslation of some lines the biggest
one revolving around Cara and shinji's
relationship now in the original
translation kuru clearly states it means
I love you referring to his romantic
feelings towards Shinji as it is clear
the relationship they share is
homosexual now
in the Netflix version this line is
changed too it means I want to suck your
[ __ ] penis and ride you like the little
[ __ ] you are until the Sun comes up and
we'd make little gay babies if we're
actually biologically possible for two
males who impregnate other no homo and
it's pretty clear why people are mad
because if you studied the subtext you'd
understand that by putting no Homer at
the end it implies what he's saying is
not gay and that's illegal in 2019 while
I understand why a lot of people are mad
about that in the franchise where every
line is picked apart and I sect it there
was always going to be something to set
people off so I think we should
appreciate all the good translation work
they've done because you know we've
still got classic scenes like this and
this and you can see they really kept
the subtlety and nuance for the dialogue
translation here so I think they really
deserve credit where credit's due and
let's not forget this scene as well
isn't there a more classic scene in
Evangelion got one job it's one word
absolutely impossible to [ __ ] are you
[ __ ] kidding
[Music]
did it cost
[Music]
you know like everyone I am offended
that they didn't get the rights to fly
me to the moon for the ending which
completely changes the experience and
almost makes the entire series
unwatchable but what's even more
offensive is what they chose to replace
it there just took an episode of Friends
and nightcore did admittedly one thing
I'm looking forward to is seeing the
revival the 20 year old best girl war
which never actually ended Oscar Rae
these girls set the stage for our modern
wife view landscape and whatever your
opinion deserves respect if you've
watched my wife retail this video you
should have an idea about who I think
comes out on top but I did miss out one
massive candidate the one who will never
betray you and will always stay by your
side who's been lurking in the shadows
this entire time that's right sitting
above everyone in ss+ tear right hands
couldn't even Gillian is the classics of
classic that has affected the medium of
anime in a way no other show has if you
haven't seen it yet there is absolutely
no excuse now watching Evangelion on
Netflix isn't just watching an anime
it's watching part of history one that
influenced the whole generation of fans
and today over 20 years later still
remains the greatest anime adaptation of
Pacific Rim that's ever been made
[Music]